aujourd'hui je vous emmène dans la rue
pour cesser cette petite enfance la de
marshall c'est là qu'il byrne 2c
d'enceinte bluetooth qui sert à orner sa
musique partout avec soi à l'extérieur
plutôt bien on fait dans un cadre un peu
urbain aujourd'hui
let's go
[Musique]
je vous fais le pitch c'est hyper simple
vous êtes avec des amis vous décidé de
sortir d'aller boire un coup manger un
barbecue faire ce que vous voulez en
extérieur on parle bien d'une enceinte
extérieure qui ne craque pas la pluie ça
c'est plutôt bien
eh bien vous prenez votre ancêtre
marshall bluetooth nom wii fit je
l'avais testé une quêté wifi celle là
elle se connecte en bluetooth
directement à votre petit smartphone je
vous montrer comment ça marche c'est
très facile
vous reprenez votre enceinte vous prenez
tout ce qui fonde la glacière et on y va
en dodon on est parti pour faire la fête
[Musique]
c'est un design marche alors marshall je
sais pas si vous connaissez maintenant
guitariste je connais depuis que je suis
tout petit ont eu l'idée en fait c'est
que vous avez une enceinte design des
amplis guitare des amplis de légende si
vous ronge dans les années 70 heavy
metal et compagnie vous avez votre ampli
marshall
on reprend donc tous les codes des
amplis qui ont fait le succès de
marshall petit gris à l'avant logo bien
évidemment marshall et vous avez même
sur les côtés
c'est petit protection ce qui fait que
lorsque votre enceinte vous l'amener à
l'extérieur si elle est amenée à prendre
des coups sur les côtés à ne crains
absolument rien petit bandoulière est
extrêmement simple sur le dessus juste
trois boutons vous avez un petit bouton
pour venir l'allumé régler votre
équaliseur au niveau des aigus triebel
régler les basses active et le bluetooth
l'intérêt cette enceinte c'est que on
pourrait se dire tiens j'ai une enceinte
mono j'ai une seule source c'est un
petit peu un petit peu pénible et bien
pas du tout en fait vous avez une
enceinte avec un son pied
multidirectionnel le son vient de former
et vient également de derrière derny
vous avez de quoi faire parce qu'elles
sont c'est vachement cool et surtout ce
qui est intéressant dans cette enceinte
c'est qu'elle est bluetooth 5.0 a pété x
l'intérêt du blue tooth 5.0 si vous
allez pouvoir connecter différents
appareils dessus vous êtes par exemple
vous avec votre smartphone votre pote
avec son smartphone est bien choisie
c'est à tour de rôle la musique c'est
assez simple à plutôt maintenant il
commence à pleuvoir et ça c'est le point
très positif vous faites toasts et des
merguez à l'extérieur il commence à
pleuvoir alors vous inquiétez pas vous
pouvez laisser dehors elle est certifiée
résistant contre l'eau alors on va
éviter les gros orages et les déluges
mais si vous avez des petites gouttes
comme ça et bien ça ne craint absolument
e
avec cette petite bête vous avez plus de
20 heures d'écouté une recharge rapide
en seulement 20 minutes pour parti pour
trois heures de musique autant dire que
si vous avez oublié de la recharger
avant de sortir et bien vous est quand
même relativement tranquille et pour une
charge complète il vous faut pas moins
de 2 heures 30 quand même relativement
aussi vous avez connu dans les années 80
90 on avait les ghetto blaster comprenez
qu'on était comme ça ça peser une tonne
c'était gros salt un certain style mais
c'était quand même relativement gros là
vous balader avec une petite enceinte
marché comme ça alors ça n'a pas le même
style qu'une enseigne ghetto blaster ce
sera relativement tôt ce par contre
c'est assez léger deux kilos et demi ça
va ça roule alors ça fonctionne
extrêmement facilement vous prenez vous
tourner le bouton de volume
ça vous sert de bouton on off en fait il
pas si vous entendez des matelas voilà
ça c'est le bouton on off c'est le
bouton de volume
une fois que vous l'avez pris ou bien va
se connecter directement à votre
smartphone qui a déjà été lui connecter
en bluetooth vous me déplaît et à la
magie opère c'est à dire qu'on est la
musique qui marche bien et ça va jusqu'à
100 décibels à un mec pour dire que
quand même relativement court
alors ces pratiques parce
qu'effectivement vous avez deux petits
boutons vous tombent assez bon thriller
devenir vraiment le choix si vous rendez
compte le son vient de mon nom mais je
n'arrive vraiment son genre
dobrygin et on peut rater
en gros l'idée cette enceinte si vous
prenez pas la tête vous tourner le
bouton vous mettez votre musique sur
votre smartphone vous fait plaisir vous
pensé à rien profité d'une bonne qualité
ce bonne autonomie design de légende que
nous en dit plus maintenant rien tant
que pratique regardez-la sais pas si
vous le voyez bien ici là c'est rouge ça
vous indique votre niveau de batterie
alors ça se recharge quand même assez
rapidement ça je vous le disais mais
c'est quand même bien comme ça à
l'extérieur et que vous savez pas si
vous reste un peu de batterie oui non
quoi comment et bien vous l'avez là ça
vole indique directement lorsque vous
venez up l'allumer et l'éteindre la même
chose que vous leur charge et vous riez
à quel niveau vous en êtes alors il faut
prévoir si vous dites on va faire un
venu pendant 4-5 heures suite eh bien
peut-être qu'il faut leur charge un peu
plus si par contre vous êtes parti pour
deux heures avec des potes apéro fritz
naxos si c'est ce que vous voulez eh
bien ça se recharge très rapidement et
ça c'est très pratique
[Musique]
côté connectique vous avez ce qu'il faut
avec ici une en coupe
elle est juste là elle veut pas partir
ici là messieurs voyez bien c'est une
entrée auxiliaire ça vous permet de
brancher de la musique qui ne serait pas
en bluetooth
si toutefois vous avez une source
extérieure qui voulait le brancher
directement jack jack et bien vous
pouvez ça c'est plutôt cool et vous
retrouverez juste ici de quoi venir le
charger sur le secteur directement en
220 volts
bon c'est simple loyer et surtout
étanche à l'intérieur ça c'est ce que
j'aime c'est très doux pour les petits
doigts fins c'est ça la vous avez
scruter très je sais ça fait penser à un
truc un peu ton beau tu vois ça me fait
penser cercueil dans les codes du métal
texte un peu gothique mais times évoque
dracula retrait dracula mais je trouve
ça pas mal je trouve ça franchement très
très jeune on a deux amplis de 8 watts
de classe d pour les twitter est un
ampli de 20 watts pour votre grave pour
votre ouf on a 36 watts de puissance
pour la marche active byrne deux
connexions bluetooth partie des dons
extérieurs est tous au tarif de 299
euros
moi j'aime ça ça plutôt intéressant
produite cool pour vivre aux bus
produits de l'extérieur produits sympas
iconique signé marshall c'est
rock'n'roll ça va s'appeler dites moi ce
que vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire comment vous la trouvez
cette marche à ce deal à dire marché
avec kilburn de est ce que doit trouver
intéressante est-ce qu'elle pourrait
vous tentez est ce que vous pourriez y
avoir est-ce que vous avez déjà des
produits de marchés n'escomptaient
guitariste s'était beaucoup de questions
vous marrer tous arborent commentaire l
on se retrouve dès demain pour utilisé
par les textes insultent les embrasse et
à demain
[Musique]